i feel fascinated i get to talk to
somebody who's about to go like fight in
like the craze like
the fight like there's a lot of people
fighting like after school next month
like that
this month that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about like there'll be maybe 12 people
there yeah but this is the fight that
this is the after school fight that
everybody is going to be at yeah
would you kill him what's going to be
different you think like heading into
this fight what do you think could be
different about it
dude every fight's different whether
it's the same opponent like this is a
rematch or
a completely guy a different guy never
fought before every fight's so different
because i'm in a different place in my
life
in my my you know life's different every
fight so
just trying to learn and uh
be smart moving forward you know not
just in fighting but in life just
trying to move with with strategy and
not emotion man and that's that's the
that's my goal you know so you feel that
for like in the ring and out of the ring
yeah yeah yeah and in preparation
for the fight not you know if i feel
like i'm redlining a little bit my
body's run down i'll pull back a little
bit
and rest up and just more about quality
than quantity at this point in my career
i still feel young and feel great but uh
i was just
my goal is to stay in love with what i
do and i feel like sometimes
i can overwork myself or put so much
into it mentally that i start to hate it
and i don't want that that's a fine line
i gotta walk right yeah cause i've been
doing this a long time
yeah i can imagine especially this past
year because there was a couple times
you were gonna fight
yeah and it got pulled back um did you
come and start a training camp at one
point and then
have to call it off yeah i think two
times that happened the tony ferguson
fight we were supposed to fight in abu
dhabi
and then uh that kind of fell apart i'm
trying to think of the other one i think
there was two times i came
thinking that i was probably going to
get a fight and ended up going home damn
yeah
but i mean it's it's not done in vain
because i come here i get pushed i learn
new things with these guys you know
surrounded by a bunch of great
professional fighters and coaches
so it's nothing lost coming and doing
that it's just the middle you know wrap
some revenue engine up and then not not
getting a raise
yeah just um when you uh
when you look at whatever you did to
prepare the first time you fought conor
to what you do
to prepare for to fight for him this
time is there anything different like
what's kind of i mean i know you're a
different person
and i know every fight is different
you're taking the fight at a different
point in your life so
you know who you are and what you're
even going to be doing is is evolved and
is
you know is coming in with a different
template but is there anything like kind
of specifically that you guys are trying
to do
you know just uh let my skills and and
work ethic and fighting
do the job you know of course the mental
plays a huge part in it
but just not getting tangled up in the
in the the mental aspect
of trying to hurt this guy or this isn't
about payback it's not a revenge fight
for me of course
of course those things are great you
know i go out there and beat him those
are all part of this storyline and all
of things that i'm gonna think about and
be happy with but that's not the driving
force
of each day i'm driven by the main goal
of becoming the world champion
to being the best and i know that a win
over a guy like this at the point of our
careers it etches my name
in the history books on its own page i'm
in the books yeah
i mean honorable mentions right now yeah
yeah yeah you know that back page
yeah that theosaurus page whatever yeah
i'm under that i'm in there somewhere
i'm trying to get my own my own numbered
page here and i think a win over this
guy does that it submits me as
a legitimate combat sports professional
in a time that that's full of great
athletes you know connor khabib um
in mixed martial arts oh yeah and uh
you know him fighting floyd it's just so
much
history involved in this fight the full
circle
fighting him again now becoming an
interim champ switching weight class
just so much going into this that
i know what a win does for not only me
and my legacy but for my family
their future financially i know i know
what comes with the win and i'm ready
my i'm ready to bear that weight now at
this point in my career man
do you feel like um have you guys had
any communication
uh me and connor yeah we uh spoke on
social media kind of got this fight
started up we were going to do like a
during the pandemic nothing was
happening and we were going to do like a
charity right i remember that event that
was real
he wanted to put that on in ireland and
uh of course if it was possible i was
going to do it
and that just kind of came out of the
blue kind of i mean i'm not sure how how
it came maybe i tweeted him or he
tweeted me something and then we kind of
went back and forth and
that's and then boom it was there
because that was because i remember you
and i were talking after the tony like
the tony thing was gonna happen
they could never get the they never got
offered you guys the right money it kind
of was back and forth
and then and then it went away
yeah and it was that feeling of like now
like kind of now what do i do
and then this i mean this came along it
was almost like
not like a blessing because i mean it's
a fight you know but it's like
it was almost like the most perfect
scenario it's the biggest fight
besides the title fight and mixed
martial arts you can get
a fight with conor mcgregor yeah maybe
even combat sports if you
if if mayweather's retired or what's
going on but i mean those two guys in
combat sports right now are probably the
biggest opponents you could be standing
across
the battlefield from so to get a fight
of that magnitude i was excited when it
came together
um and i know what like i said what it
brings a win over connor
brings a lot more exposure and and it
brings a title shot
do you think like uh do you have any
like keys going into the fight like um
if we get
to this far then i have this better
chance or i'm you know
that i have this different strategy i
mean i know some of you might not want
to share but
like going into it is there just
something
because the first i just ended in the
first round you know and i'm sure that
feels just so deflating because you like
you never really
you guys were just kind of getting into
the dance yeah i didn't even get to
fight you know the fight didn't even get
to blossom
you know i uh but that's fighting
anything can happen under those lights
i um i want if you tell my game plan
what i want is for us to
to both be dripping blood and and
hurting and suffering early in the fight
then we can find out who's the real
fighter you know that's what i want i
want to be bleeding
with a minute off the first round clock
i want
to be bleeding and really have to dig
down and see who's the better fighter
see who really
wants to be in there you know because i
don't have a safety net
this is i want to be in there yeah and i
know that
i know that and uh i'd like to find out
if he does
damn [ __ ] and and i don't and i
that's uncomfortable you know yeah
i'm not looking forward to getting
busted open but if we can get the fight
to that point to
both of us are tired and bleeding then
we can see
who has more grit and who has more want
and i think i win that fight 10 out of
10 times
dang bro damn yeah you're one of those
psychos bro i'm not sorry no offense
you're right here but
you're one of those guys that like you
like to go it's almost like you're like
one of those guys that like repels like
a spelunker
you like to just rappel into the depths
of your own freaking
darkness man and just and [ __ ] see
what's in there bruh
yeah yeah yeah yeah sticky things back
in the day you throw them on the wall
and they would kind of like
climb down the wall yeah yeah like that
into the depths of hail no i i
i no but i think you've always said you
learned something about yourself there i
mean you told me one time that you look
like eve
in a fight win or lose that you there's
something that coming out of the other
side of a fight that you're just a
different person
yeah yeah it's like a spiritual
pushing yourself and going out there and
i can't it's hard to explain but
coming out and going through the fire
you're a little bit different
um every time i i feel
do you um conor's like a celebrity you
know connor's like i mean he's like the
billy elliot of ireland basically and
do you is it different fighting like a
celebrity do you feel like like is there
any added
thing to it does it feel different than
fighting just a fighter
maybe on the lead up to it uh there's a
lot more cameras around this training
camp there's a lot more
interview requests and media requests
and all kinds of things like that but
other than that
the actual fighting part is a fight you
know none of that comes in there with
you
so i don't think it's going to be any
different when the cage locks and the
bell rings it's gonna be a scrap
you know and at this point in my career
all the extra stuff like i've been doing
this long enough and done so many
interviews and videos and it's not a big
deal anymore i don't enjoy doing it all
i like to train i don't want the camera
there when i'm in training camp but it
was there a lot this time but
i think this is my sixth main event in a
row so all these past
events have been full of media as well
so it's just kind of
the normal i guess dude i don't want the
camera there
they had the camera there today when i
was training here at this gym man and it
was
yeah you know i might have to run a
wheelchair man it was
got a little rocky at the end um
do you feel like when you think back to
your first fight with connor and uh
and if you and if i'm bugging you
talking about just let me know dude
nothing's off the table i'm i'm
i'm comfortable because it's fascinating
with anything i feel fascinated i get to
talk to somebody who's about to go
like fight in like the craze like the
fight like there's a lot of people
fighting like after school next month
like th
this month that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about like there'll be maybe 12 people
there yeah but this is the fight that
this is the after school fight that
everybody is going to be at yeah
um clock strikes noon yeah man i mean
people are going to be there bro i'll be
sick of this
sucking on my bag of milk um
do you do you think when you think back
to the first time you fought you were
i mean were you nervous going to that
one do you feel differently going into
the fight now
i i feel more confident in who i am i
know who i am now
i know what i can take i know um the
depths i might have to go
the uncomfortable limit that might get
reached in there i'm okay and more
understanding of those things and
accepting of them
but uh
yeah i just we got to get in there and
and and
and start moving around and and just i
want to get in there and feel the rhythm
and
feel the feel what's going on you know
i'm excited to to
get in there and i don't know what's
going to happen yeah that's the thing
you know and that but that's why i'm so
uh i'm confident like i said in my
preparation
and the fighter i am i know i can trust
myself when it gets ugly in there
but um that's why i'm not scared to talk
about anything because there's no
it's truth fighting is truth like i
can't go in there and and then pretend
or fake it in there you know what's
going to happen is going to happen i'm
going to win or i'm going to lose it's
white and black there's right
no gray area so i'm not scared to talk
about any of those aspects
about fights because there's nothing to
hide
you're going to see it january 23rd
you're going to spend the 60 bucks on
pay-per-view
and you're going to you're going to see
it so there's no reason to even try to
beat around the bush
i'm prepared i'm focused i know i can
beat anybody in the world
i feel like i'm one of the best 155
pounds walking the earth
at this given time damn bro that sounds
almost egyptian when you say it i uh
hieroglyphics
yeah and that's just it man a lot of the
work has been done you've done a lot of
the work yeah and i think a lot of times
i was fighting um
i was i was accomplishing things that
maybe my skill but that's tough to say
my skill level wasn't there yet but i
was
beating guys and rising up through the
ranks and and getting myself in
in big fights but i was just learning on
the job and i'm still doing that you
know i'm still learning i'm going to
learn on the walk to this one i've been
learning all training camp
this is a whole new journey i have to go
to abu dhabi i have to quarantine in
vegas
um you know i'm leaving this weekend
this is usually i'm still sparring and
still doing strength and conditioning
now i'm getting on flights and
quarantining so it's just a different
landscape in 2020 or 2021 to go out and
and put on one of the biggest events on
pay-per-view in fighting
and i'm just rolling with the punches
you know that and that's just it
but i'm confident in the work i put in
and like i said i know i can beat
anybody in the world
i just have to be mentally in the moment
that's what that's where this comes down
to i need to be in the moment to execute
you know execution is worshipped man and
i just need to be able to execute that
night
you know 25 minutes he can be better
than me the rest of the year i just need
25 minutes january 23rd that's not even
a half hour now that's dude
my daughter was conceived in less time
oh damn right hey i believe it yeah so
i've done some things myself but yeah
yeah but that's just
that's that's fighting that's life
that's where i'm at mentally i feel like
a lot of years
maybe my physical was here my minnow was
was catching up or
you know but i feel like it at next uh
in the next couple weeks i'll be 32
years old i feel like the physical in
the middle has finally started to align
and i'm
and i'm just at my prime right now yeah
yeah you know a lot of the uh
you know connor's definitely a guy who's
been you know he has like the most
flamboyant you could have i mean he's
the rick flair almost yeah yeah
he's like the irish rick flair you know
uh and he does it
super well yeah he is i remember like
there was a time where you and i talked
a couple years ago and you're like
that's not really your thing you know
like trying to be that
i understand it but it's just not yes
it's not your thing and i
did you feel like at a point that maybe
you wouldn't be able to get to certain
levels of
popularity because you didn't have that
but but now you've gotten there with
your own way
yeah i'll just keep gunning it out you
know keep working keep grinding
and and hopefully one day put myself in
a position to fight for the belt which i
have
i'm trying to do it again here but i'm
not going to go that route you know i
understand it i understand it's
entertainment and stuff like that i just
don't
don't like it man yeah yeah it's a it's
a turn off for me even when i see other
guys do it i'm like oh [ __ ] some of it's
too much
yeah some people yeah they bring a
little they gotta go for something on
them they do something yeah
they're doing wow they can bring voodoo
dolls or whatever
yeah they don't there's no limits yeah
it's getting wild
do you feel like it's getting weirder
overall though or you feel like in the
end it's going to stay kind of where it
is
i think it's going to stay where it's at
i i think uh since kind of first
came on the scene i've seen a huge rise
in it you know like a lot of guys that
started trying to
yeah sugar shawn's a guy he's a guy that
likes the pump and the
you know i've seen more of it since
connor became a superstar you know
but also you have to be able to fight
you can't just be a joker out there
getting your ass away
yeah yeah you can't go out there and
juggle a couple times and get your ass
beat yeah yeah yeah
then you're at the like state fair yeah
yeah yeah
uh do you um do you uh
do you how do you see the fight kind of
playing out do you envision that kind of
thing like what do you
yeah but it's just like so many ways it
could play out
he does his kicks early remember yeah he
throws a lot of
spin kicks will kicks he's a good
athlete man he's impressive
oh yeah it's almost like it's like uh
watching that cap aware that brazilian
dance kind of like he has a lot of that
in him yeah
he he does and he gets his long good
comparison
um a little bit of unpredictability with
the spinning kicks and and stuff like
that and the shoulders and and
knees you know it's a it's a no holds
barred fight though so those things
are expected right you know anything can
happen but i i really feel like i'm
gonna go out there
and be more in tune with the flow in
there
touch him make him miss and i just i
just want the fight to blossom and i
want to see who's the better fighter
yeah
and like i said i think we need to be i
can suffer more
i i we we need to be damaging each other
and we both need to dig down
and i want it to be that kind of uh
performance i want it to be gritty i
want to leave a piece of myself in there
and i want him to do the same and i want
to see who gets our you know who comes
out with their hand raised
i envision i eventually a lot of
different things happening and and the
fight going different ways but at the
end i always envision
me winning you know getting back on that
long flight home
with the win come and see my daughter
that that feels so good you know and
whatever it takes to get to make that a
reality i'm willing to do so let's just
go
would you kill him i don't want to i
i mean i don't want to yeah i don't want
to kill anybody
yeah i feel you man yeah but that's not
that i'm not that's not a goal yeah
that's not a goal okay
i like that i respect that bro yeah yeah
you don't want to be that guy
no i don't wish that on anybody yeah
you're right man i shouldn't even ask
that
um yeah you never know
you know what if years from now we find
out that you were a serial killer in
lafayette you know
people would be like i knew it bro he
had it in him you know yeah
i mean but i never admitted it yeah but
he never admitted it bro
dude that'd be so gangster if you were a
freaking ufc champion and a serial
killer that's crazy dude i'm watching
the thing on a unabomber right now that
dude is [ __ ] weird man yeah yeah
did he seem interesting at all or no
yeah dude he lived in a shack out in the
woods
and he was mailing bombs and leaving
clues and stuff what a weirdo
yeah he took a [ __ ] in his neighbor's
bathtub and left him yeah
dude i'll tell you a good story so my
friend used to be a moving man like a
furniture guy you know
and he had to work for regis philbin one
time and move his furniture and he
said regis was so rude to him that he
ended up taking a crap in his bathtub
and left it in there
nice you ever had he ever met any bombs
i know he didn't do any of that man
i don't know he never really went to
that next level yeah he stayed on that
yeah yeah he said on that yeah but
that's a special place too though that
is
a special place dude what if you ever
say one day you retire years down the
road 15
25 years down the road uh we should do
like some fight campaign or something
that'd be fun huh
if i learned enough about fighting i'd
have to learn a lot more yeah
you kind of inspired me i was like man
maybe i should do a
talk about fighting podcasts or
something like that but then i just
thought about
all the other stuff i have going on and
man i just i don't know if i can have
time to do it you could do it later
yeah yeah you got a lot going because i
would love to talk about fights you know
yeah i really would yeah
do you feel like that now do you feel
like you kind of uh cause i remember we
talked in the past maybe about
a school or something you're like i
don't know if i would really want to do
that
do you have any different thoughts on it
now but you're still like in it though
yeah and i just signed a new eight fight
contract with ufc
my plan is to fight fight eight more
times you know i want to finish this
this contract i'm on eight fights fight
eight more times and we'll see
where we're at there but i'm not looking
past that or before that i'm gonna fight
eight more
times that's crazy dude i don't know if
the world can handle it more
dude i don't know if my brain can't
they're good
yeah yeah dude that last one was a rough
one man that was a while yeah yeah
i remember yeah you came back after oh
yeah it's like you were there bro thanks
for coming out yeah
no worries yeah that was awesome that
was exciting and then you wanted to sit
and then we sat and watched the fight
dude that was so cool
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
brown